[Music]
what are you doing
good evening Saint Paul it's your city
news at five I'm Jamie throneberg and
I'm Marcy whitchurch
weather advisories are in effect across
central Minnesota tonight with more on
that weatherman Isaac laboda Isaac
thanks Marcy a major system is zipping
across the region outside temp right now
eight degrees but it feels like 20 below
Jamie well stay off the roads if you can
folks lots of reports of black ice
watch out for that dangerous black ice
it's transparent and sneaky hard to see
black ice that's right Marcy keep your
loved ones safe and warn them to stay
off the streets tonight because of
menacing life-robbing black black ice
Isaac
we have Channel 17's field reporter
Darren hempner with more Aaron
[Music]
yeah I'm standing out here in historic
Ramsey Hill where there are currently no
cars on the street due to uh
hazardous driving conditions Darren are
you talking about black ice
that's right
Jesus it's frightening just to even say
black ice it's scary tricky ruthless
stuff that black ice uh perfectly safe
neighborhood can be suddenly terrorized
by the appearance of Black Ice well
one must keep in mind that just because
black ice looks different than white ice
it doesn't make it any more dangerous
also one must remember how hard it is
for Black Ice to survive what would the
authorities trying to destroy it with
the snow plows and the salt trucks but
black guys persevere that's right that's
right and as you can see right now the
city is being controlled by lots of
oppressive white snow making it hard for
all people to advance and we don't hear
much news about that now do we no we do
not well thank you very much brother
Darren but let's be honest black ice is
the real Menace last night I was in a
perfectly safe neighborhood walking away
from an ATM machine when black ice just
snuck up on me and practically robbed me
of my balance ouch that sounds exactly
like something black ice would do well I
just hope that folks watch out so the
white snow doesn't blind them and keep
them from seeing what's
going on all I'm saying is I can't think
of a single Christmas song about black
ice lots of cheerful uplifting songs
about snow so oh well for the record
black ice never asked to be out here no
it did not it's a product of the
environment
oh Hallelujah
in fact black ice didn't land on the
road the road landed on black ice
okay next up why is America being ruined
by black people
[Music]
would you look at the time you should
just stay ahead of night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I dare you to try it I don't wanna fight
[ __ ] you online died
[Music]
please just please go away you wanted me
to stay well I just changed my mind
how did this all switch now you are
[Music]
please just be kind to know how your
mind
[Music]
show me out son
now you're gonna end up with a bullet in
your head for it
you can't play mean mothers
I'm the [ __ ] that plays
[ __ ]
cut
all right everybody let's get reset we
are going again
Nigel that's great oh great it's
smashing thank you so much yeah well
it's been an absolute honor and and what
a great opportunity to be here and be
able to play an American tough wow I'm
just so glad that we got you out of that
BBC commitment so you can play with us
Cheers Cheers Cheers Antoine listen I'm
just now buying that you're someone that
was born and raised in the streets of
Brooklyn
that's weird because uh I actually was
born and raised on the streets of
Brooklyn
I wasn't a gang and everything most of
this stuff it's actually happened to me
wow okay well that's that's that's great
for us because I want you to use it okay
it's good first take let's just uh let's
get going let's go let's get going thank
you chief
scene five take two
and action
so meow son
now you're gonna end up with a bullet in
your head for me
you can't play me [ __ ]
I'm the [ __ ] that plays mother's
mother
cut cut
okay uh Nigel that was great oh
brilliant just the way you move
especially when you talk I just really
see this character coming to life before
my eyes cheers it's fabulous Antoine
your performance
um
just not quite there yet okay I really
need to see you make more of a
transformation okay like like Nigel here
that was British Anton if I might jump
in with a bit of advice I don't think I
need no no no no look hear him out maybe
you might want to try thinking of
something in the material that's similar
to something that's happened in your
real life but for me for instance I like
to think of when my mom wanted me to
attend Prep School in Leeds to become a
barrister but I wanted to study the
theater at Oxford thank God and so that
was a conundrum really for me I'm gonna
stop you right right there because it's
just confusing me right like I don't
need that because I am from the streets
I was in a gang
they told me to kill my cousin
to be a [ __ ] Sports hard no yeah that's
a good spot on do you have any stories
that involve your mom
what's a mum
oh dear scene five take three
okay
Antoine remember you're a gangster okay
betrayal the streets
okay Nigel you're perfect and one
transform and action
sold me out son
now you're gonna get a blood up in your
head for it
you can't play me [ __ ]
I'm the [ __ ] that plays
[ __ ] mother
he's boring to watch
cut
oh that does not sound good
I do not feel like you have found the
emotional core of this character
this nobody is more real than me okay I
come from the streets and nobody's gonna
tell me what the streets is like nobody
you understand
that's a great speech I just wish that I
believed it you want to give it a shot
so I'll have a go ma'am this I'm as real
as you guess yes this is freezes for
real imma be in there man you are from
the from the
from the Earth from these streets
something to that defense no but I'm so
with you I'm with you when you say that
even when you're saying the wrong words
I just wish you could do that
[Music]
oh goodness
okay that hurts but I don't feel that it
comes from the right emotional place for
the character all right here give it a
shot give me watch watch
oh that's that's great I feel that in
here and in here in my heart try that
again
I just I don't I don't believe you
foreign
you got
Lemon Zinger Lemon Zinger like that tea
oh
what's wrong oh no what's going on
I got that brain freeze oh man the [ __ ]
you do yeah
relax man that [ __ ] will pass man calm
down
um
come on man you say you from the hood
dog you acting weak right now with this
brain freeze
[Music]
come on ain't no brain freeze gonna make
you yell like that man get over don't be
hitting your head with the brain freeze
come on in it yo you want silver balls
on it silver balls on the shrink
Connecticut
what are you doing now well you doing
some Kung Fu get over it man listen it
can't be doing this much to you listen
man don't be a punk ass [ __ ] man get
over the way you afraid now you see
anything you're just scared the brain
freeze make you scared
me who am I you ain't got no Alzheimer's
what's wrong with you
you're a punk ass [ __ ]
Three Stooges on this [ __ ] this
is some craziness oh let me do the hand
block
you know what man you're weak man you're
a weak ass [ __ ] that's the
problem
[Music]
hold up now hold up now hold up now hold
up now hold up man you're gonna continue
to eat the Froyo even on top
what are you doing hey now I really
start to respect you now man if you're
gonna eat the thing that's causing you
the pain this is great about to go
faster
he's staring into the brain freeze this
[ __ ] is straight crazy right here come
on real Taco Real Taco Real Taco I mean
he's crazy in the time man that strangle
Benny with my bare hands cause he didn't
have my money all right we got him kahoo
what
what's your five oh stand up slowly
I've known you since sixth grade you
under arrest for the murder of Benny
tech there are tricks get him out of
here hey man you a punk ass brain freeze
[ __ ] you going to jail for a
long time
I'll be too deep
inside I got the brain freeze
I'm not caught with the brain freeze
yeah you got that brain freeze get him
out of here
[Music]